[Music]
in couple collision news Oh like a sexy
temp collision hopefully mmm
submitted by baby panda Oh anything baby
panda sneeze achoo and then the mom you
scared oh yeah yeah so turns on a
honeymoon collide while ziplining
leaving the husband dead and the wife
injured
oh my [ __ ] dope so they put two people
on the same line and then went one
didn't communicate I'm sending someone
to you what I've never seen a zipline do
that [ __ ] dude what we zip like that
match safe the first one was too heavy
and stopped and then the second one
couldn't stop oh like that and then
actually huh well I don't know because
she was heavy but the wife was first she
was like halfway down and then the
husband comes in and smashes into it but
that should never ever eat I'm I go zip
line and then the next person they never
send some people in the [ __ ] middle
yeah but apparently this the plane is in
America in Honduras I knew it
[ __ ] han doors where's Han doors at
Honduras is where they [ __ ] build
Honda's Central America and to America
that's right on the honeymoon
yeah and yeah they actually got married
the day before they went on this should
have went to Japan [ __ ] is mad safe
there nobody dies there yes ever
impossible that people like 4000 years
like turtles how how fast or do you go
for you to die ask you a question [ __ ]
well they're saying that this ziplining
is 40 miles long and five miles wide
whoa that's the city my bed I was a dog
that's like the world's long as if a lot
of you just see me at the end just
knocked out
40 months okay so the the ziplining tour
is 12 zipline twelve zipline double
gliding parallel cables 18 platforms and
for hiking trails is what the planing
tour consists of the longest cable
stretches 1950 feet and the highest
reaches 300 feet above ground but the
one that they were specifically on I'm
not sure
so did did the wife she did fall 60 oh
no that's something else
sorry good did the wife the husband the
husband died who was in the middle first
the wife and then the husband collided
with her and then did his thing snap and
idiot Gaia so they they don't they
haven't officially said what it was but
they're speculating that it might have
been a brain aneurysm oh oh just from
the impact yeah well he was alive he
died in the hospital
oh they are reporting that he was
complaining that he couldn't breathe and
so they gave him oxygen and the
ambulance and then later on he died he
was 24 years old oh the wife is 27 she's
now like she's still in like serious
condition but [ __ ] how fast is or do
people so old it likes yeah like in
perspective so she didn't stop because
she was too fat if you're too light you
don't get to go across because there's
no momentum there's no like kinetic yeah
yeah so the bigger you are the faster
you go yeah yeah and I was implying you
together right yeah I was going like a
bullet [ __ ] no we try to race
Suzanne and David David I actually was
the fastest buyers are those the weight
in the speed like it was funny cuz
they're like oh you should go on an
average of like maybe like 20 miles an
hour or something like seven I was going
like 40 like it was [ __ ] ridiculous
man they were telling the girls like you
probably want to like jump start it and
then do a cannonball yeah because they
almost didn't make it
I didn't have to cannonball whatsoever
so they are like you should cannonball
here so you can make it across look at
me like you don't have a cannibal
superfast
it was [ __ ] frightening dude I was
trying to catch up to him like in
flexible like right I would have a jump
start I would push myself cannonball and
I'm like going as like fast as I could
but it would do in Hawaii what would
happen if you'd like stop halfway do
these are like a hook that they come and
grab you like I stopped halfway and
they're putting it yeah I haven't seen
anyone stop halfway but there were think
it was a girl that couldn't make it all
the way but she was almost there so all
they had to do is just reach and pull
her in yeah yeah another way that they
do it is like the like a person will
they'll strap on and then they'll shimmy
to you and then ziplining that must be a
crazy one cuz I don't I don't remember
it being so fast well there's 12 line so
and it didn't feel fast to me well how
how many wines did you guys have there
was a lot yeah but it doesn't feel fast
in relative relativity to what we're
doing but if you're staying there and
somebody comes at you at 30 miles an
hour and you're honest tense it's
literally like a hundred and fifty
pounds coming at you at 30 miles an hour
Wow yeah you can buy yeah so this couple
they were from Israel here's some photos
of when they were being put into the
ambulance should have went to Japan you
married too early to 24 men you had such
a good life ahead of you did 27 he's 24
yeah that's so sad this is how to have
fun apparently this isn't the first time
they've had at this apply this zip line
yeah apparently you got to read the Yelp
reviews homie I know so this is all part
of they took a cruise freak show they
took a cruise out of Florida and then it
was one of the like activities that they
could have won there
on land so this is that and ten years
ago there was this woman who was
ziplining there and the cable snapped
and she fell sixty-five feet
the cable snap you know those things are
[ __ ] metal ass thick ass cables right
three years ago another woman walk she
was visiting and she was just seriously
injured blaming they don't say how well
it's this it's this company
oh yeah thought that theme the [ __ ] is
it called dat zip no welcome to that zip
con durian durian no it's on this island
so it's an island called wrote on so
it's the largest island in Honduras [ __ ]
man in that theme island it's one of my
worst nightmares ever dude dying or is
it boy what the camel snap it in half a
new fall is 65 feet yep there's nothing
you could even do at that point he's got
a hope you don't die is it [ __ ] that's
what the the first thing that I told you
guys that's the island measurements of
40 miles long five miles like have you
guys ever felt like going hella [ __ ]
fast doing something yeah what are you
doing like on a bicycle rollerblading on
a skateboard once and then like you know
when you just go super fast you [ __ ]
eat [ __ ] all that [ __ ] as a kid never
happened you don't like freeways those
freeway overpasses where curves like
this yeah I had one where I was on
rollerblades and I was going down a
hella fast and like back in those days
you take the brakes on to roll the [ __ ]
do you look like a little [ __ ] I had no
rollerblades yeah you break like like a
[ __ ] all saw back in it before so it's
like this is during when the rollerblade
and skateboards like they were equally
cool before the skateboards made the
rollerblades look whack so that was like
a brief moment it was very weak returned
all the blades from the x-games and they
were still getting [ __ ] okay
mmm way that you were supposed to stop
with the rollerblades is like
like like yeah well when you're coming
down the overpass you're just
accelerating and when I slammed at the
bottom I knocked the [ __ ] out and I just
woke up with soda all over because I was
carrying soda but like the whole time
you just see the end of the well cuz
we're getting we're getting a [ __ ]
slaughter from Dunkin Donuts and I
didn't want to drop this I'm just
holding and I'm like I literally I was
going fast as [ __ ] and I really didn't
know what to do I'm like my fate is at
the end of this thing you're not like
what am I gonna do I don't know boom and
I wake up and I'm like wait did I get
knocked the [ __ ] out and there's just
soda all over me in a month
oh [ __ ] no what that's a scary place as
a kid when you're going when you start
at the hill and you start going you're
like [ __ ] yeah this feels good and a
half way through you learn oh sure yeah
and then you you have to be confident
enough to make sure you hit that slope
right so you don't eat [ __ ] but then
what happens is you freak out and that's
why you send it flying like that yeah
because there's a point of no return
you're just like so you got to commit
remember we still on board down that big
hill next to our house it's like that -
why do we do this Gary's is doing jumps
in snowboarding because you just [ __ ]
going fast and there's no way to stop it
nobody is the worst because that boards
attached to your [ __ ] feet yeah
completely which I'm actually glad
though because cuz it's attached to feet
so imagine you're on skis now right
you're up in the air and like let's say
one of them pops off you're like [ __ ]
cuz then at least the snowboard will
always be there so you're like I just
got a [ __ ] balance back and land on
this but if you have it's like losing a
parachute yeah like if you're jumping
out of a plane their parachutes gone
you're like oh well yeah I've never done
ah you would love it wait how could you
do it the last time we went to Big Bear
because you guys did it the first day
when Casey and I couldn't go Wow
I didn't brand deals again god damn it
no it's good I'm Isaac [ __ ] children
did you shoot a bribe you would have had
fun on the bunny school school school
Shmuel yeah schools for fools no you
would love snowboarding you like that
[ __ ] no boarding and been a great parent
no Britt knots no burning shoes but like
the fatter shoes snowboard boots yeah
that all right well this wiener we're
[ __ ] going you're coming with us Rick
and then you guys can get snowboard
lessons yep I'm gonna have Tiger
strapped to me and we'll go on what I'm
not gonna do the crazy [ __ ] but he'll
love it
he loves riding on the bike right here
you won't know what the [ __ ] is going on
you gonna have his mouth open and all
there's gonna be a year old dude he's
not a bicycle ride on he loves it
remember I had me old man I'm not
hitting jumps and he's got my head jumps
but he loves that stuff
[Music]